thank you
[Music]
welcome back to cuerado Migos amigos
amigos
Jesus
[Applause]
yes okay okay saying a lot call himself
a stupid uh China China man yeah China
right China well welcome back Jesus by
the way you know what's [ __ ] up Latino
called every Asian person
that's the same thing but they don't
even like describe it like that they
just call it like it's our [ __ ] name
how do you guys
I prefer when they say chinito like a
small a little Chinese
yeah when I used to work with a lot of
Mexican homies
um at the warehouse they would um they
would call me by my name they were never
in the office
mommy mister or they were coming and
then once I felt accepted Easter is when
they call me they call me Paisano oh and
I'm not like me I'm your Paisa all right
cool
you're in hey look how crazy
[Music]
don't take offense of that I feel like
it's never used in a negative
connotation anytime Mexicans always said
Chino is like in the term of endearment
right yeah
I've never seen sad Mexicans either do
you look like this do they make those
yet you see them on the side of the
freeway they don't even look sad they're
like happy to sell you a flag this is
either life is miserable they're living
under the bridge
[Laughter]
you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
just a floss straight back to the eggs
go back to their miserable huts and be
like hey do you want to say hi you know
I came to the town I know you have five
kids with a guy who's a bum drinks all
the time but uh I'm making money in the
states
hey does it work though it works though
[ __ ] yeah it works dude look at the big
belt buckle from the swap meet with a
snake on it and [ __ ] they'll be like
look at this check out this snake belt
buck tell you Dude that [ __ ]
citizenship American citizenship gets
you a lot of places dude especially in
Mexico you can get any [ __ ] in Mexico
dude you go to a club in Mexico you
don't even have to hit on them you hold
your passport up you want you want
citizenship [ __ ] they're just like oh
yeah yeah the [ __ ] don't leave me for
a drug dealer you know what I mean right
here yeah
zero dependence wow
yeah sorry it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's going on patreon all right all
right all right yeah please watch out oh
boy right now dude hey man Spanish words
you know yeah what other Spanish words
uh donde estas
that's a standard what the [ __ ] is that
that means where's the tango ungato and
me pantalones I don't know he's got a
cat sound those are the basic like I
don't know why the [ __ ] everybody
learned that [ __ ] Spanish one potato
[Music]
that's it wrong already
then Spanish class like Peggy Hill's mom
I mean uh Bobby Hill's mom because I
learned it from rotarya oh
that's good
dude always make you [ __ ] win
scorpion right that's the one
everybody's looking for
does your son taika recognize that he's
Mexican now oh yeah he goes I speak
three languages oh I don't know what do
you speak he goes Chinese Spanish and
English but he knows like English and
then one word in each
what's the word
in Chinese he knows uh Apple like and
then my grandma uh my mom's been calling
him smart so toming what are those two
words and in Spanish he knows uh Sandia
Sandia
first grade teacher he's gonna be like
holy [ __ ] this guy where he was he made
okay he's all over the place you know
that's the biggest
um like interracial marriages in
California now is Asian and Latino dude
Joe's been studying animation
Americans pop up
Latina Latinas are going for nice guys
now I think they're [ __ ] nice like I
am down for like an Asian because
they're nice
you know what I think happens because
you ages are very calm and chill Latinos
are just like what the [ __ ] you talking
about you don't [ __ ] know me like
that you're like all right well I guess
I want to get to know you again
and [ __ ] Latinos are just like oh
well [ __ ] [ __ ] you then you can get
to know me [ __ ] what about me and
there's like arguments and they make a
baby who does the same [ __ ] and just
over and over and over sorry to trauma
dude
I think they're all just they're both
they're both they're both married to
Latinas both oh yeah Latina eating in
nursing school right they're all beating
up at the hospital yeah everybody every
time I tell someone I'm uh I'm married
to us okay you're about to take it yeah
every time
every time I tell people I'm married to
a gay is that what you said no every
time I tell people I'm married to a
salvi they always go like oh [ __ ] you
better watch out yeah that [ __ ] is
crazy yeah I'll say that but she but she
pretty chill but there are moments she's
so chill but there are moments where I
go who are you like when she gets like
really the Latina fire comes out yeah
bro that [ __ ] but like why did you
[ __ ] argue with me in my dream yeah
yeah like like when you guys go to
you're a [ __ ] mean to me in my dream
but you know I'm trying to be more
machista you know oh I'm trying to be
more of like a [ __ ] man of my
household dude you see that [ __ ] is it
working like that dude I do like that no
wonder he's been doing Jiu Jitsu and
[ __ ] is it more of an attitude because
obviously people whoop her ass
yeah first of all I like that first of
all that's going to turn her on to relax
yeah I'm like I could wreck and then you
pull a guard yeah
I'll pull your arm off your socket you
can whoop ass so her her specifically
yeah you can I mean obviously because
she's like you know she's like 105
pounds right I'll [ __ ] and she's
injured right now too so you just gotta
kick her leg Yeah yeah she's a [ __ ]
injured leg just kick the [ __ ] sweep the
leg
come on come on but they like that huh
they like that I don't know if she likes
that because she looks at me like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about she
pretty normal though she I think she's
she's quite level-headed when you're
around her dudes in her family yeah does
she want you to be more no I get along
with them pretty well yeah like we hang
out outside like her and her cousins
like we [ __ ] we chat we have our own
group chats without her into it you know
that's tight you hang out with you drink
with them I don't drink but I kick with
them oh yeah I don't drink with them
they just they're not big drinkers these
guys but Latinos they they cool the
first hour and then once they start
getting loot they start their eyes go
from like yeah if I get to hey homie you
wanna know something though yeah and I I
never hey homie I never liked you homie
I'm straight on I never [ __ ] liked
you homie but you know what now you're a
[ __ ] cool guy you know you're just
like are we cool are we not cool
you ever do something to her I'll do it
to you
that's how it gets dude they start off
cool and then that you know I mean they
don't go to therapy I mean yeah so this
is their thing
you know how many uncles I've drank with
and they're just like everything starts
off cool funny stories and then I bring
up a story about their dad and there's a
itching up he never loved me
yeah but Grandpa remember that Christmas
and he came in all drunk he was crazy
yeah he never used to beat me he's like
all right there
do you have your personal uh rankings
for uh Latin women for the amount of
either fire or type of yeah it's like
does everyone go like oh Cuban girls
they're the craziest
oh cause we have that in the Asian one
yeah oh we'll compare lists we have the
most I heard that uh uh I heard
that um
[ __ ] I don't even know my list might not
be accurate the same okay
you don't come at me at the comment
section you know what I'm all about it
let's be racist let's just save space I
heard that that uh
um
like that those girls are like the
hottest but the craziest Venezuelan
Venezuela chicks they're like hottest
but craziest like they're like they'll
switch up on you real [ __ ] because
they've been living under communism for
so long and that's what it is that's
like North Korea you know what it is
like they like control but not that much
eh yeah like [ __ ] tickets
I like you keeping tabs but are not that
[ __ ] much to it I'm gonna do what the
[ __ ] I want to do because of that [ __ ]
you know Trump Colombians are like known
to be like
hot and and all that but so both of them
are just hot dude it comes the Coast
it's like a lemon swellings I heard that
they're [ __ ] like top tier like hot
like even the ugliest [ __ ] is like God
damn yeah
even like the war is like that's a bad
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying and then
Colombians and then they're ugliest is
All American seven Latinos is like
argentinians they're just like very
fancy they're just white people oh yeah
they just like you know judge everybody
after they want to be they feel like
they're perfect are they borderline
they're more like they're like white
people almost yeah they're like kind of
like yeah they're kind of like Europeans
a lot of Nazis ran away to Argentina did
you know that yeah which is interesting
yeah which is interesting and a lot of
argentinias and Nazi uh interracial
marriages have been happening the
biggest population
yeah which also understands like they
just want Argentina they don't want to
mix with other people that's crazy you
know what I was thinking about like like
Latino right I felt like let's just so
you know how America it's like English
British culture that's just mixed when I
think of Latino it's like it's like it's
still european-ish but it's mixed but
it's spanish-based that's basically what
it is right but it's European still like
but because you know okay you know
America English-speaking countries are
not Spanish-speaking countries so like
so like like so basically in America
right my brain went
[Applause]
when they think of a Latino they don't
think of them as white but there's a lot
of white people in Latin America they
just speak Spanish like all the weather
ladies yeah but they look a hundred
percent European they look they look 100
European like like about people that
live in like a lot of people that live
in Mexico City a lot of them look really
white that's what I'm saying no because
I've been in Mexico and all that and
then like there's a lot of well he tried
anyway homie what are you trying to say
that I feel like you're being
disrespectful there's a lot of there's a
lot of yeah disrespecting me in a weird
way and I don't like it there's a lot of
Spanish there's like a lot of
Spanish-speaking Europeans right yeah or
they look European but they're from like
South America and then when they come to
America they don't consider them white
even though they're pretty much European
I see that's from my Asian ice that's
what I'm saying it's like it's like
Premier Chino eyes from South that's
that's what I'm saying in South America
to me it's like
they don't cap to me it's weird how they
categorize race in America oh where they
look at them as like Latino but then I'm
like but half of them are white like
Jill's Mom right blonde with green eyes
she comes here they call her [ __ ] but
exactly but then but she's more white
than than Asians
Latinos considered her to be white so
she was stuck in no man's land yeah
but like in South America what I'm
saying is like there are people that are
100 European but all they do is speak
Portuguese or Spanish so that's why
they're considered a minority in America
but they're white I say yeah yeah
genetically yeah but also that's what
I'm dealing with too like my generation
is dealing with that [ __ ] because it's
like we're born here right but when we
go to Mexico we're not considered Mac
full Mexican we're like oh you're
American Gringo Gringo because my
Spanish is is not as like good as theirs
yeah and they come to the United States
and they're looking at all you're
Mexican but it's like yeah but I'm not
because I'm American and it's just like
yeah so we're in this weird pocket of
like passports where am I getting
accepted at and then that's why people
like created the name Chicano Chicano
yeah so Chicano became the thing of like
your your Mexican-American what about
latinx how do you feel about that yeah I
don't know I don't know who made that up
or what's going on a white woman was
just concerned I feel like we need to
just change it all all right I'm pissed
for them it's just like why [ __ ] I
didn't complain you know what I mean
like nobody like people did not complain
about that and they just decided to add
wait wait you're telling me right now on
JK yes you're not supporting latinx bro
whoa dude whoa dude
yeah
dude I do not support Landing I'm
confused by latinx it's dumb isn't it it
is dumb very dumb there's no Asian
accent I know we can't we don't know who
actually made latinx he's probably right
it's probably a white woman lady my
dumbass first time I read it I was like
latinx
little tanks yeah that white woman came
to the office and she just went
Cheryl is everything okay no it's not is
it Latina Latino what's going on
I don't know what to call my my maid I'm
so confused
ain't that the truth well what would you
like us to call it
that [ __ ] everybody just crisscrossed
all right he's looking okay make it
happen I wonder if it has anything to do
with like gender because you know that's
what it is that no that's why latinx is
is because they're like oh the masculine
yeah like why is it like Latina why is
it Latino and then it's just like Latino
oh you're Latino and she's just like
well I'm a Latina and then they're just
like confusing people you're like latinx
come on [ __ ] accidents sounds like
you're about it I think you're turned I
think it sounds pretty good X looks good
on you yeah dude I'm gonna wear a hat
just as an X you're changing all the
words so even like puto it's just boot X
dude
okay
[Laughter]
let's regroup
jolex
[Music]
[Laughter]
I went down a deep dive of like well I'm
like what am I supposed to say right
like because there's Hispanic there's
Latino and then have you seen where it
says hispanic white hispanic whatever
right and I was like what the [ __ ] does
that mean and what I found out is
there's a group of Spanish descendant
white people in like the Texas New
Mexico area and they consider themselves
white but not American anglo-white
because they're European like from Spain
that's where their jet like ancestors
are but they're that's why they're
hispanic white that's why I was like
what the [ __ ] does all these things mean
a lot of those government [ __ ] um
questionnaires are weird as [ __ ] so if
I'm filling it out for my son oh right
right it'll be like race and like for
race there's only like two like white
Hispanic or white non-hispanic or
whatever and then I'm like well he's not
he's not yeah I guess he is Hispanic
because I click that and then it goes to
ethnicity and then you would think like
certain bubbles like either delete
options or expand on options and then it
goes ethnicity and it goes like Asian
and I'm like I think that's true
I am Asian
Asian
white Asian Hispanic person on the other
end the guy's like what kind of freak is
this
dude there's a guy in the office
[Music]
what the [ __ ] hey Greg get in here
someone's [ __ ] around their system
even the Braves over here just like I've
never seen such a human before Oh My
Gosh Jason Bourne oh my God he's my next
I'm just like clicking all the bubbles
but then I clicked all the bubbles out
of fly but yeah like when you look at it
you're like this person doesn't make
sense I don't have to look forward to it
just went multiple choice yeah but but
it's everything's truthful it just
doesn't make sense
you are a churro [ __ ]
but I think that's why you have to press
other and you just make your own [ __ ]
other slash this slash a real
[ __ ]
period I love the guy buying a computer
doing a spin take
[Laughter]
god dude
that's [ __ ] that's classic right
there
laughs
foreign
[Music]